good morning everybody you're very
welcome to our press conference today on
the protocol on ireland and northern
ireland i'm joined in the press room
today by vice president mahesh
chefchaouich who will react to the
announcement by the uk government
good morning on monday the uk government
tabled
legislation confirming
its intention to unilaterally break
international law
more precisely to break an agreement
that protects peace and stability in
northern ireland
an agreement that we reached together
only two years ago
let there be
no doubt
there is no legal
nor political justification whatsoever
for unilaterally changing an
international agreement
opening the door to unilaterally
changing an international agreement is a
breach of international law as well
so let's called
a spate expect this is illegal
the uk bill is extremely damaging to
mutual trust
and respect between the eu and the uk
it has created deep uncertainty and
casts a shadow over our overall
cooperation
all at the time and respect for
international agreements has never been
more important
that is why the commission has today
decided to take legal action
against the united kingdom for not
complying with significant parts of the
protocol on ireland northern ireland
we have been withholding this legal
action over the last year
because we wanted to create a
constructive atmosphere to find
solutions
the uk government's decision has left us
with no choice but to act
first we are proceeding a step further
with the infringement process we
launched in march
2021 regarding for instance the movement
of agri-food
if the uk doesn't reply within two
months we may take them to the court of
justice
second
we are launching two new infringements
against the uk
one for failing to carry out the
necessary controls at the border control
posts in northern ireland by ensuring
adequate staffing and infrastructure
and one
for failing to provide the eu with
essential trade statistics data to
enable the eu to protect its single
market
ladies and gentlemen
the protocol
was the solution agreed with the uk
government to protect the good friday
belfast agreement in all its dimensions
avoid a hard border on the island of
ireland
and protect the integrity of the eu's
single market
we know that there are some practical
difficulties in implementing it
we have said so openly
that is why my team and i
had been engaging extensively with all
stakeholders
on the grounds resulting in a set of
solutions put forward in october showing
genuine and unprecedented flexibility
for example our proposals would reduce
sanitary and phyto-sanitary checks and
controls by by more than eighty percent
they would cut customs paperwork in half
create an express lane for goods moving
from great britain to northern ireland
simplify certification a single
three-page document for whole glory full
of different goods
and they would
allow even the movement
of certain goods that would otherwise be
restricted such as chilled meat like
sausages
this is a solid offer
making a tangible difference on the
ground
today we have fleshed out these
proposals proving
they can work and they can work fast we
have even published the draft
certificates that businesses would need
to fill out showing just how simple and
easy they are to fill in
and i would like to show it to you
these are the three pages which needs to
be filled
perilously or one
once per month not 300 not 33.
this is how simple it is and this what
we can do if we work well together
because our proposals are all about
simplification
and therefore in stark contrast with for
instance a dual regulatory regime
proposed by the uk
a dual set of rules eu and uk
would lead to a mountain of paperwork
and bureaucracy
enough to bury a small business in
northern ireland that wants to profit
from access to both
the uk's internal and eu's single market
at once
so once again
permanent solutions and simple
operations of the protocol proposed by
the eu versus
constant uncertainty with uk ministers
having an open hand to change the rules
on a whim
we want northern ireland to embrace the
all benefits of this unique position
because our commitment to the people of
northern ireland is unshakable
despite today's legal action our door
remains open to dialogue
we want to discuss these solutions with
the uk government
given that the uk hasn't sat down at the
table with us since
february i think it's a high time to
show some political will to find joint
solutions the uk has stated that for us
to talk
the eu must be willing to change the
protocol
on the contrary we have always said that
our package of proposals has never been
a take it or leave it offer
it can evolve
but it is not an unconditional offer
there must be safeguards included
that protect the single market
because the risks for our market are
real not theoretical
and the conditions which allow northern
ireland to access the eu single market
for goods are not for the uk to change
it's simply legally and politically
inconceivable
that the uk government decides
unilaterally what kind of goods can
enter our single market
this is not the path for the two
partners standing shoulder to shoulder
when facing global challenge
challenges and that
should be
forged like that
i'm convinced that with political will
we can find solutions for people and
businesses in northern ireland but this
must be done jointly thank you
thank you very much vice president we'll
now take a few questions just to let you
know first of all we have published
press material online as well as the two
position papers which the vice president
referred to including the documents that
he showed so you'll find all of that
online uh adam please first
uh adam parsons from sky news uh mr
cerfkovic
there are lots of people here in
brussels who think that the european
commission is being played by the
british government for its own domestic
concerns
do you have trust in the good faith of
boris johnson and liz truss
and if not were you tempted to go harder
and further with the legal proceedings
that you've taken against the british
government or do you still have those
options up your sleeve
thank you very much for that question of
course
i think our today's action the fact that
we have to start the legal proceedings
and legal action against
our ally against
our our partner
in this uh very difficult times where we
face together the global challenges is
pretty telling what the level of the
trust
we have
at the same time we
are fully
aware of the current circumstances
in the world in europe and in northern
ireland and therefore for us
the peace on the island
and our commitment to the people of
northern ireland
have
i would say overriding
uh principle in
how we
approach these negotiations therefore we
decided that our response should be
measured
should be proportionate
and
we are offering not only legal action
here today but we've been fleshing out
what concretely we could do i was just
showing showing you
three pages of the of the certificate
three pages
and i can also tell you that
what we are fleshing out in our today's
proposals exactly responds uh to the
queries to the questions to the
propositions i heard when i personally
visited northern ireland and what i
heard since then because i i'm in
regular contact with the business
community with civic society and to the
political leaders in
northern ireland what they what they
want us to focus on is is to straight
reduce administrative burden make the
operation of the protocol as smooth as
possible and this is exactly what we are
what we are doing
and what we are offering is joint
solution which would offer stability
which would offer legal certainty which
would offer legal clarity
and
when you are talking to the to the
business operators and
potential investors what you hear from
them you know
for us it's very important to know
if we are going to invest are we going
to produce for 5 million
50 million or 500 million
and that has i would say
very important uh implications we
offered and promised
the people of northern ireland to have
the best of the both worlds
and this is what we want to offer them
what we are now getting
in form of this draft bill would be the
mountain
uh monstrous mounting of paperwork
which
uh the business operators in the
northern northern ireland will have will
have to fill up i mean go and ask
i don't know the milk producers in in
northern ireland
how how he or she can produce the milk
one sort for eu another one for the uk
or any kind of manufacturer
who wants to benefit from the access
to both markets of the uk and the eu
should have two different production
lines so so therefore what i'm what i'm
saying here is let's focus on
practicalities let's focus on how to
make the operation of the protocol
smooth and this is what what we are
going to do therefore our response today
uh is measured therefore it's
proportionate and that's that's the
reason why we also are fleshing out that
what we are putting on the table it's
really oven ready
if you have a
positive reaction from the uk side
political will and engagement this can
be done in no time as we did it with the
medicines
we demonstrated we can sort out a very
difficult issue within very short period
of time and what we are offering here
are ready-made recipes how we can solve
the problems of sps checks problems of
customs procedures and
as i said
we always been ready to discuss other
issues as well but there was radio
silence from the uk site since february
thanks uh jessica parker from bbc news
um just to ask you if this stalemate
continues and the uk persists with its
legislative plans how far are you
willing to go would you hit the uk
with tariffs even suspend the whole
trade agreement
and also you say you won't renegotiate
the text of the treaty but if that could
open some further doors to compromise
why won't you do that
i think i will start with the with the
second part of your questions i'm sure
that you've been
uh following the the the brexit
negotiations in a great detail and you
know that it took us
more than four four years to find that
delicate compromise where first and
foremost
we took the interest of the northern
ireland people
into
most appropriate account because for us
what was the of paramount importance was
to protect the peace and stability in
the in the northern ireland to avoid the
hard border
on the island and protect the the single
market and we've been pondering over
these issues for years this was the best
solution which we found together i have
to say that
concrete
northern ireland unique
solution we've been developing at the
expresswish of the uk government
we after laborious negotiations where
we've been really going
through the very demanding text line by
line
we agreed upon that
we
sign it it was ratified and
now we cannot we cannot imagine that we
can come up with something better which
would correspond to this three
priorities peace no hard border
protection of the eu single market on
top of it
giving the northern ireland people and
operators this unique opportunity to to
have access to 500 million potential
customers which is the only place in the
world which has it
and
therefore we are ready to
show that uh the agreements we
negotiated the protocol we agreed upon
offers us enough
uh legal and political space to make
sure that the operations could be smooth
that the checks could be inobtrusive if
we finally get the proper access to the
to the it and to the to the to the data
we are talking indeed about very very
limited uh
checks with a three-page certificate
with uh
i would say a few
a few few tracks being checked if they
would go
through this green lane
based upon the
risk assessment by both uk and eu
authorities and everything in the world
work perfectly well and therefore we are
ready to invest additional efforts
additional imagination into this
discussion but we are not going to
reopen the whole discussion renegotiate
the protocol withdrawal agreement
which uh
was
approved and ratified
just uh two years ago
thank you bruno
bruno waterfield times of london um you
said just just now at the beginning you
said let's call a spade a spade this is
illegal
and you were talking about the northern
ireland build yet the infringements
you're talking about today have got
nothing to do
with that bill at all they've got
nothing to do with something that is
illegal something that you say
is a breach of international law
something that's very very serious in
fact the infringements you're opening uh
today about to do with the
implementation um of the protocol
nothing to do with a northern ireland
bill
at all in um infringements that um you
could have um either
taken forward uh or introduced um early
stage so why is it that why you call a
spade a spade something that's illegal
you're not actually prepared to do
anything about it at the moment
i think we are i think
we are
i think we are pretty clear
in uh our reaction uh to the bill i
think i'm making it even clearer uh this
morning when i when i say that
the bill
as it was drafted and tabled its illegal
period
and
i think that
i should also add
one additional argument that there is no
doubt
that
there is no legal justification
whatsoever for unilaterally changing an
international
agreement and
i'm sure the uk government knew
perfectly well what they sign up to
when they agreed to the protocol
although i have to admit they didn't do
a very good job
explaining it to the public
and most importantly it's simply legally
inconceivable that the uk government
decides what kinds of uh
goods can enter the eu a single market
and i have to tell you that yesterday i
i had the extensive session with the the
members of the european parliament we
had access
extensive session with uh with the
member states and it's it's quite clear
that the
position of the eu on this one is is
absolutely uh united and the protection
of
uh our single market is a key interest
for the whole eu and the member states
and we just simply cannot accept that
the uk would simply unilaterally change
an
in in this respect
so coming back up uh to the first part
of your questions we are just
um
arguing uh with our infringement of of
today
that the the key
uh parameters of
the arrangement which you've been
working so hard to achieve
within the protocol with sps check speed
customs
procedures beat the sharing of the
information so we can safely say to
our member state the single market is
protected simply are completely
disregarded and i i have to say and i'm
i'm very sorry to stated that
since the march of the last year i
haven't seen any constructive idea how
to smooth the operation uh in a joint uh
partnership way coming from the uk there
have been only new and new demands
coming from the uk government uh
very often and not even one mention once
mentioned in the discussions i had with
the northern ireland
partners so what i want to say is that
by today's actions from one side
we're showing that we will be quite
resolute in uh defending european single
market but from other side we're still
open for the negotiations because we
believe that the joint
solutions will bring
needed legal certainty clarity stability
to to the island of analysis would be
the best message uh for peace it would
be the best message for the people in
northern ireland and uh the business
operators there that actually are the
only place in the world which have uh
the this unique access
uh to both the uk and the eu single
market and i know how interesting
interesting this proposition is for
investors who are just waiting and
hesitating should we come in should we
wait what would be what would be what
would be the the future what would be
the the legal framework within which we
would operate
jennifer
thank you jennifer rankin the guardian
um
concerning the the infringement
procedures the
the
uk has made it clear it will go ahead
with this bill that doesn't recognize
the role of the european court of
justice so what does the commission do
if at the end of the infringement
procedure process the uk simply doesn't
recognize the verdict of the court or
any fines that might have to be paid and
to follow up on a question i i didn't
hear you answer my colleague's question
about how far is the commission willing
to go
will the commission is the commission
prepared to impose tariffs on british
goods is the commission prepared to
suspend the entire tca thank you
i think that
the role of european court of uh justice
in a
ruling on the matters
of the european law is very clear it's
clearly reflected in the withdrawal
agreement it's clear clearly reflected
in in the protocol
and not respecting not respecting the
european court of justice
rulings would be just piling
one breach of the international law up
upon another
as the uk wants to go in in that
direction
when the rule of law is something what
we are discussing at uh every
international forum these days it's it's
the way forward is it is it
compatible with the proud
british traditions of upholding and
respecting the the rule of law
and international law in that regard so
that's i would say the the the political
question i'm i'm i'm uh
i'm throwing up
and
of course how other potential partners
would look at the uk
when they will be negotiating the
agreements with them will they be
changed in one year in two years will
they will they stick well they will be
respected i think these are of course
the questions for the uk government to
respond but i think that for us the best
way would be let's come back
on the safe grounds of respecting our
treaties respecting international
international law and respecting
the the agreements and commitments we
made to the to the people in northern
ireland that we will sort of this
problem that we will we will uh focus on
unintended consequences of the protocol
that we would make uh the protocol
of operations as smooth as possible and
we would create these additional
opportunities for the northern ireland
businesses because i think this is
clearly very important and you know
looking at the economic performance of
the last year i i think that northern
ireland did quite well and of course i
do not want to go into the deep
analytics of that but i'm sure that
the the access to the single market was
was part of that good performance
and coming back to
uh to your question and the question of
your colleague on the on on the tca
we are now bringing uh the the argument
also into the
into the debate which i'm sure will be
in house of commons house of lords
that
there is better way
to solve
these issues
than having this legal dispute with the
eu
then uh acting unilaterally
and that
alternative which i'm sure would be
welcome uh by the people in northern
ireland and by the
international community
is
work on the joint solution
smoothing the operation of the of the
protocol and working on this together
and despite of
all
this and our experience of the past 18
months we are ready to do that our doors
are open we are ready to engage on how
to make sure that the operation of the
protocol are as smooth as possible we
have recipes we know how to do it we
demonstrated it with a medicines issue i
just show you
how the certificate could look like how
it would be smooth for the salisbury uh
trucks supplying the operators in
northern ireland
you've been informed how
what we suggested in the concrete terms
concerning the trustee trader scheme so
there is a lot of opportunities what we
could do and how we could tackle this
issue so we expect that also the debate
uh in the british parliament be it in
the house of commons and house of lords
will take some time of course
if this draft bill
will become the law then of course i
cannot exclude anything
but we are not there yet and we want to
solve this issue
as the two partners should
through negotiations
looking for the common ground and
delivering for the people in northern
ireland
okay i'll take one final question joe
thank you joe barnes from the daily
telegraph um so one of london's main
complaints with the current protocol is
that while it's an operation the dup
will not enter storm on and that's why
they're saying it doesn't respect the
good friday agreement
um so do you think the uk government is
being disingenuous with that or will you
be willing to potentially move further
by putting stuff uh extra stuff into law
maybe adding changing the eu's customs
laws to accommodate
more changes on northern line or do
something to proclaim the dep or do you
have another plan for kind of convincing
the dup to come into stormont
to kind of please the british government
thank you
of course forming the the the
uh the assembly and the executive
it's uh for the people of northern
ireland to decide it's uh for the
uk uh
government
uh to work on with the political parties
in northern ireland we have no intention
to interfere in this process we've been
very clear from the beginning and uh i
think the protocol it's absolutely
explicit on that that we respect first
and foremost good friday belfast
agreement in all its dimension and we
respect also uh constitutional and
territorial arrangements of the uk so i
we cannot be clear on on that fact and
as you know i i have uh the regular
meetings with the political leaders in
northern ireland and i was very explicit
and i will repeat it
here as well
we do not seek a political victory here
we do not seek a political victory what
we want is to find workable
long-term
[Music]
solution based on the law giving the
legal certainty to the operators
in
northern ireland
on how
the the protocol would be
implemented
as you know the
european union is a peace project and
and we've been supportive of the
good friday belfast agreement from its
outset a bit politically a bit
economically bit financially beat by
different projects which i had that
privilege to visit when i was in
in uh
in northern ireland
flurry bridge schenckel road
center in in belfast and and it made a
lasting impression on me how important
this is and how we should remain
committed
to build up on what was what was already
done over the
uh last
two decades how important it is for the
people in in northern ireland and that's
our contribution i'm just saying very
openly we want to work with all parties
we want to find the solutions but what
we need is a political will
from london to engage with us
to work on smoothing operations
and implementation of the protocol and
to do it in a way
that it would bring the lasting benefits
for the people of northern ireland
thank you very much vice president this
now concludes our press conference thank
you very much to colleagues and to the
interpreters for uh for working in this
press conference uh stay tuned for the
press conference by the president at 12
o'clock all the way from egypt thank you
very much
so
you